- My way of expressing myself
has always been physical.
My mom told that since I was little
if I would be angry or happy or whatever
you would see it in my body language.
For me having a new way
of challenging my body,
a new way of pushing the
limits of what my body can do
that was the thing that really
got me hooked in flying.
My name is Inka Tiitto,
and I'm a dancer and a world
champion indoor skydiver.
(bright inspirational instrument music)
I started dancing when
I was three years old
and as long as I remember
I've been dancing.
When indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about
than I ever was about dancing.
Suddenly I realized, like,
"I've just found a new way of dancing,
"it's just on a different
kind of dance floor."
The discipline that I compete
in is called freestyle
but when I'm speaking
about my flying overall
I prefer to use the term air dancing,
because it's not just about competing
and that set discipline.
It's about creating something new
and exploring the limits of
what we can do in flying.
And I would like to take flying
from being a sport towards
being a form of performing arts.
Flying for sure is way
harder than it looks like.
The wind speeds can go
up to 180 miles an hour.
You have to be strong,
you have to be flexible.
A lot of the body positions look easy
but they actually require a
lot to perform them nicely.
So a split, for example,
it might look like
I'm just resting in that
flexible body position
but I'm actually, all the time,
pushing against the air
flow to have control.
(uplifting inspiration music)
I don't always like the
use of the word talented
because it makes it sound like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're gonna get good.
I've always been like a hard worker myself
so if I really wanna get good at AirDsomething
I'm gonna do whatever it takes.
It just depends on how much you want it.